Hey, what's up guys?
I'm at the hot springs today with my doer [?] of liquid nitrogen and we got a pool over here
that's a hundred and four degrees Fahrenheit.
What does liquid nitrogen do when it hits hot water?
You're about to find out.
Now, this liquid nitrogen is -321° Fahrenheit and the water in these hot springs today is 104° Fahrenheit.
You do the math on that.
This is what happens when you pour liquid nitrogen Into hot water:
(Children shout and laugh excitedly)
Yeah, what's really cool about this is as the nitrogen hits the water it kind of flows over it like a rolling tide.
And that mist you see is actually water vapor
Yeah!
Check out these beads, these are so cool!
You can even grab them with your hands.
The thing that I noticed is the water is still incredibly warm and that's because water has got a really high thermal mass.
It takes a lot of energy to cool it down so a little liquid nitrogen is no big deal.
My little buddy Reece-Man wants a turn; what are you going to do right now?
I'm'll [?] let the nitrogen in!
All right, let's do it. Let's check it out.
Job. Good job, buddy, good job.
Wow!
That was amazing, Reece!
The water is fine!
What do you think of all this craziness?
It was great.
Feels so good!
Feels like I'm in a cloud.
It looks like you're in a cloud!
Well guys, that was super awesome,
and I'm pretty sure nobody has ever done something like this at these hot springs before.
Super fun to have you along for the ride and I'll be looking for you in the next video.
Talk to you then.
Can you pour liquid nitrogen down water slide while I'm going down?
Not liquid nitrogen but maybe we can do some dry ice.
Oh yeah, yeah! Yeah, dry ice!
I can't believe they let us do that!
(Laughter)